now we can't ignore that last week I
came to you and told you Fox News
reporter Bret Baier went on Fox News and
said my FBI sources who I won't name are
telling me a Hillary Clinton indictment
is likely I never said it was false I
got a few emails from people saying
David you're you're not really citing
any evidence when you say Brett Bayers
report is false I never said his report
was false I said it was a report with no
actual evidence it was a report that
might just reflect the desires of the
anti-clinton enclave of the FBI that now
we know within a rien II reasonable
doubt absolutely exists and indeed I was
right this report was completely bogus
Fox News embarrassed itself hugely and
has had to retract it but as Kellyanne
Conway said and I'll play it for you in
a second the damage is done now let's
start this is just a reminder about what
Bret bayar said this is part of what we
played for you last week Bret they are
saying an indictment is likely that
later on and that he downplayed it in
today he said something that suggests
that he's changed his tune a bit about
about director Comey this does not sound
like something that's going to be
completed anytime soon which suggests
that if Hillary Clinton is elected she
will take office with not one but two
serious investigations of her past
conduct hanging over definitely and I
pressed again and again on this very
issue and these sources said yes the
investigations will continue there's a
lot of evidence and barring some
obstruction in some way they believe
they'll continue to likely an indictment
well well-bred liar thanks buddy thanks
come across the hall dandiya show and
help us enter a very serious a very
somber a very professional and grave bet
bear Bret Baier who happened to be
saying things that were completely false
he ended up having to apologize for it
these apologies are just the best I'm
gonna play part of it for you i love it
all the time but especially in the
heated election on the topic this
explosive every word matters no matter
how well sourced which brings me to this
i explained a couple of times yesterday
the phrasing of one of my answers to
britt hume on
Wednesday night saying it was inartful
the way I answered the last question
about whether the investigations would
continue after the election and I
answered that yes our sources said it
would they would continue to likely
anodite minh el that just wasn't in
artful it was a mistake and for that I'm
sorry I should have said they will
continue to build their case indictment
obviously is a very loaded word John
especially in this atmosphere and no one
knows if there would or would not be an
indictment no matter how strong
investigators feel their evidence is
it's obviously a prosecutor who has to
agree to take the case I want to be
super clear here right as Bret Baier
spoke for about four minutes I pay
played for you the key part way says the
indictment thing was wrong he apologized
for the indictment part but mostly he
stood behind the story in terms of all
the investigation is growing its
accelerating more serious than we
thought now we know because of James
commis most recent letter that there's
just going to be no charges against
Hillary Clinton but even this whole
thing about the investigation is way
bigger than we think ABC News reported
that quote there has been no change in
posture for the investigation NBC News
Peter Williams reported that quote FBI
officials tell me there has been
virtually no movement on the Clinton
Foundation inquiry for months and months
and months the entire report was bogus
and Bret Baier pat just apology for this
one little piece of it it's almost like
an i apologize if people were offended
the indictment thing may not have been
true but everything else is well no
almost none of it was true yeah it's
really just the case of Fox News trying
to tell its viewers what they want to
hear regardless of what the actual
reporting is it's good that he did give
some form of apology you usually don't
see that from fox news now usually
that's left for other cable news outlets
to give tearful expanded apologies now
here's the problem though it had an
impact and Trump campaign manager
Kellyanne Conway admitted that yet it
was wrong but it has had an impact and
that is the problem here's Kellyanne
Conway your candidate today on the stump
a quote from Donald Trump it was
reported that an avalanche of
information is coming in the FBI agents
say their investigation is likely to
yield
and indictment this has been walked back
the indictment portion by Fox News who
originally reported it and by NBC News
which has done subsequent reporting on
this will Donald Trump amend his stump
speech to walk back the same thing well
the damage is done to Hillary Clinton oh
no matter how it's being termed the
voters are hearing it for what it is a
culture of corruption we see reports
tonight it confirmed by different
network Ryan that that there are new
emails that have to do with Hillary
Clinton in this Anthony Weiner laptop
situation I suppose Kellyanne Conway is
completely right you can't unring the
bell the uh I guess I've workable
calling it what the first letter after
the the one last week where James Comey
said hey we're looking into this stuff
that had an impact uh early voting is
now done now we know yeah there's not
going to be a single charge against
Hillary Clinton that is a representation
of what the Trump campaign is depended
on for this entire of a harebrained run
for the presidency misleading those who
were dumb enough to be misled and it has
a real impact and Kellyanne Conway is
right and it's great that Bret Baier
apologized and it's great that we
finally got to the bottom line with
James Comey but this had an impact Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
try-on to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / tdps I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high
$300 for prescription glasses hi which
is just insane Warby Parker glasses
start at $95 that's what mine cost and
for every pair of glasses sold Warby
Parker distributes a pair of glasses to
someone in need you can try five pairs
and see what you like check out the
at-home trial and support our show by
going to Warby Parker dot-com / TDPS it
costs nothing